francia culpable de inacción climática
esta es la decisión inédita del tribunal
administrativo de parís en lo que se
conoce como el caso del siglo después de
dos años de investigaciones los jueces
determinaron que francia no puso en
obras suficientes a políticas para
cumplir con los objetivos que se ha
fijado en la lucha contra el cambio
climático uno de ellos la disminución
del 40% de el efecto de los gases de
efecto invernadero de aquí a 2030 y esta
inacción es considerada ilegal todo esto
pues es el fruto del trabajo de cuatro
ongs apoyadas por cerca de dos millones
de ciudadanos la audiencia tuvo lugar el
pasado 14 de enero y hoy el estado pues
está condenado a pagar un euro simbólico
a estas cuatro ongs pero lo importante
de esta decisión es que la justicia
encontró que hay un vínculo directo de
causalidad entre la inacción del estado
y el impacto del cambio climático sobre
las sociedades esto abre la puerta a que
personas que se consideren víctimas del
calentamiento global por pérdida de
ingresos porque no pueden vivir en un
ambiente
adecuado y sereno pues puedan también
entablar demandas en contra del estado
además de esto pues el tribunal se da un
espacio de dos meses para determinar
cuáles son las órdenes que va a dictar
le al estado en esta materia